MICHALE FEE: OK, let's
go ahead and get started.
So today we're turning
to a new topic called
that basically focused
on principal components
analysis, which is a very
cool way of analyzing
high-dimensional data.
Along the way, we're going
to learn a little bit
more linear algebra.
So today, I'm going to talk
to you about eigenvectors
and eigenvalues which are one
of the most fundamental concepts
in linear algebra.
And it's extremely important
and widely applicable to a lot
of different things.
So eigenvalues and eigenvectors
are important for everything
from understanding energy
levels and quantum mechanics
to understanding the vibrational
modes of a musical instrument,
to analyzing the
dynamics of differential
equations of the sort that
you find that describe
neural circuits in the brain,
and also for analyzing data
and doing dimensionality
reduction.
So understanding
eigenvectors and eigenvalues
are very important
for doing things
like principal
components analysis.
So along the way, we're going
to talk a little bit more
about variance.
We're going to extend
the notion of variance
that we're all familiar
with in one dimension,
like the width of a Gaussian
or the width of a distribution
of data to the case of
multivariate Gaussian
distributions or multivariate--
which means, it's
basically the same thing
as high-dimensional data.
We're going to talk about how
to compute a covariance matrix
from data which describes
how the different dimensions
of the data are correlated
with each other, what
the variance in
different dimensions is,
and how those different
dimensions are correlated
with each other.
And finally, we'll
go through actually
how to implement principal
components analysis, which
is useful for a huge
number of things.
I'll come back to many of
the different applications
of principal components
analysis at the end.
But I just want to mention
that it's very commonly used
in understanding
high-dimensional data
and neural circuits.
So it's a very important
way of describing
how the state of the brain
evolves as a function of time.
So nowadays, you can
record from hundreds
or even thousands or tens
of thousands of neurons
simultaneously.
And if you just look
at all that data,
it just looks like
a complete mess.
But somehow, underneath
of all of that,
the circuitry in
the brain is going
through discrete trajectories
in some low-dimensional space
within that high-dimensional
mess of data.
So our brains have something
like 100 billion neurons
in them-- about the same as the
number of stars in our galaxy--
and yet, somehow all of
those different neurons
communicate with each
other in a way that
constrains the state of
the brain to evolve along
the low-dimensional trajectories
that are our thoughts
and perceptions.
And so it's important to be able
to visualize those trajectories
in order to understand how
that machine is working.
OK, and then one more comment
about principal components
analysis, it's not
actually the best way
often of doing this kind of
dimensionality reduction.
But the basic idea
of how principal
components analysis works
is so fundamental to all
of the other techniques.
It's sort of the base on which
all of those other techniques
are built conceptually.
So that's why we're going
to spend a lot of time
talking about this.
OK, so let's start with
eigenvectors and eigenvalues.
So remember, we've been
talking about the idea
that matrix multiplication
performs a transformation.
So we can have a vector
x that we multiply it
by matrix A. It transforms
that set of vectors
x into some other
set of vectors y.
And we can go from y back to x
by multiplying by A inverse--
if the determinant of that
matrix A is not equal to zero.
So we've talked about a number
of different kinds of matrix
transformations by
introducing perturbations
on the identity matrix.
So if we have diagonal matrices,
where one of the elements
is slightly larger than 1,
the other diagonal element
is equal to 1, you get a stretch
of this set of input vectors
along the x-axis.
Now, that process of
stretching vectors
along a particular
direction has built into it
the idea that there are special
directions in this matrix
transformation.
So what do I mean by that?
So most of these vectors here,
each one of these red dots
is one of those x's, one
of those initial vectors--
if you look at
the transformation
from x to y going--
so that's the x that we put
into this matrix transformation.
When we multiply by y,
we see that that vector
has been stretched
along the x direction.
So for most of these
vectors, that stretch
involves a change in the
direction of the vector.
Going from x to y means that
the vector has been rotated.
So you can see that the green
vector is at a different angle
than the red vector.
So there's been a rotation,
as well as a stretch.
So you can see that's true
for that vector, that vector,
and so on.
So you can see, though, that
there are other directions that
are not rotated.
So here's another.
I just drew that same
picture over again.
But now, let's look at
this particular vector,
this particular red vector.
You can see that when
that red vector is
stretched by this
matrix, it's not rotated.
It's simply scaled.
Same for this vector right here.
That vector is not rotated.
It's just scaled,
in this case, by 1.
But let's take a look at
this other transformation.
So this transformation produces
a stretch in the y direction
and a compression
in the x direction.
So I'm just showing you a
subset of those vectors now.
You can see that,
again, this vector is
rotated by that transformation.
This vector is rotated
by that transformation.
But other vectors
are not rotated.
So again, this
vector is compressed.
It's simply scaled,
but it's not rotated.
And this vector is stretched.
It's scaled but not rotated.
Does that make sense?
OK, so these
transformations here
are given by a diagonal matrices
where the off-diagonal elements
are zero.
And the diagonal elements
are just some constant.
So for all diagonal matrices,
these special directions,
the directions on which
vectors are simply scaled
but not rotated by that
matrix by that transformation,
it's the vectors along
the axes that are scaled
and not rotated--
along the x-axis or the y-axis.
And you can see that by
taking this matrix A,
this general diagonal
matrix, multiplying it
by a vector along
the x-axis, and you
can see that that is
just a constant, lambda
1, times that vector.
So we take this times
this, plus this times this,
is equal to lambda 1.
This times this plus this
times this is equal to zero.
So you can see that A times
that vector in the x direction
is simply a scaled version of
the vector in the x direction.
And the scaling factor
is simply the constant
that's on the diagonal.
So we can write this
in matrix notation
as this lambda, this stretch
vector, this diagonal matrix,
times a unit vector
in the x direction.
That's the standard
basis vector,
the first standard basis vector.
So that's a unit vector
in the x direction
is equal to lambda 1 times
a vector in the x direction.
And if we do that
same multiplication
for a vector in
the y direction, we
see that we get a constant times
that vector in the y direction.
So we have another equation.
So this particular matrix,
this diagonal matrix,
has two vectors that are in
special directions in the sense
that they aren't rotated.
They're just stretched.
So diagonal matrices
have the property
that they map any vector
parallel to the standard basis
into another vector
along the standard basis.
So that now is a general
n-dimensional diagonal matrix
with these lambdas,
which are just scalar
constants along the diagonal.
And there are n
equations that look
like this that say that
this matrix times a vector
in the direction of a
standard basis vector
is equal to a
constant times that
vector in the standard
basis direction.
Any questions about that?
Everything else just flows
from this very easily.
So if you have any questions
about that, just ask.
OK, that equation is called
the eigenvalue equation.
And it describes a property
of this matrix lambda.
So any vector v that's
mapped by a matrix A
onto a parallel vector
lambda v is called
an eigenvector of this matrix.
So we're going to generalize
now from diagonal matrices that
look like this to an arbitrary
matrix A. So the statement
is that any vector, that
when you multiply it
by a matrix A that gets
transformed into a vector
parallel to v, it's called
an eigenvector of A.
And the one vector that
this is true for that
isn't called an eigenvector
is the zero vector
because you can see that a zero
vector here times any matrix
is equal to zero.
OK, so we exclude
the zero vector.
We don't call the zero
vector an eigenvector.
So typically a matrix,
an n-dimensional matrix,
has n eigenvectors
and n eigenvalues.
Oh, and I forgot to say
that the scale factor
lambda is called the eigenvalue
associated with that vector v.
So now, let's take
a look at a matrix
that's a little more complicated
than our diagonal matrix.
Let's take one of these
rotated stretch matrices.
So remember, in
the last class, we
built a matrix like
this that produces
a stretch of a factor of
2 along a 45-degree axis.
And we built that matrix
by multiplying it together
by basically taking
this set of vectors,
rotating them, stretching them,
and then rotating them back.
So we did that by three
separate transformations
that we applied successively.
And we did that by multiplying
phi transpose lambda and then
phi.
So let's see what the special
directions are for this matrix
transformation.
So you can see that most
of these vectors that we've
multiplied by this
matrix get rotated.
And you can see
that even vectors
along the standard basis
directions get rotated.
So what are the special
directions for this matrix?
Well, they're going to be
these vectors right here.
So this vector along
this 45-degree line
gets transformed.
It's not rotated.
It gets stretched
by a factor of 1.
And this vector
here gets stretched.
OK, so you can see that
this matrix has eigenvectors
that are along this 45-degree
axis and that 45-degree axis.
So in general,
let's calculate what
are the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues
for a general rotated
transformation matrix.
So let's do that.
Let's take this matrix A and
multiply it by a vector x.
And we're going to
ask what vectors
x satisfy the properties that,
when they're multiplied by A,
are equal to a constant times x.
So we're going to ask what are
the eigenvectors of this matrix
A that we've constructed
in this form?
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to replace A with this
product of matrices, of three
matrices.
We're going to multiply
this equation on both sides
by phi transpose on the
left side, by phi transpose.
OK, so phi transpose times
this, is equal to A sabai, x
subai, times 5
transpose on the left.
What happens here?
Remember phi is a
rotation matrix.
What is phi transpose phi?
Anybody remember?
Good.
Because for rotation
matrix, the inverse,
the transpose of a rotation
matrix, is its inverse.
And so phi transpose phi is just
equal to the identity matrix.
So that goes away.
And we're left with
lambda phi transpose
x equals A phi transpose x.
So remember that
we just wrote down
that if we have
a diagonal matrix
lambda, that the eigenvectors
are the standard basis vectors.
So what does that mean?
If we look at this
equation here,
and we look at
this equation here,
it seems like phi transpose x is
an eigenvector of this equation
as long as phi transpose
x is equal to one
of the standard basis vectors.
Does that make sense?
So we know this
solution is satisfied
by phi transpose x is equal
to one of the standard basis
vectors.
Does that make sense?
So if we replace phi transpose
x with one of the standard basis
vectors, then that
solves this equation.
So what that means
is that the solution
to this eigenvalue equation
is that the eigenvalues
A are simply the diagonal
elements of this lambda here.
And the eigenvectors
are just x, where
x is equal to phi times
the standard basis vectors.
We just solve for x by
multiplying both sides
by phi transpose inverse.
What's phi transpose inverse?
phi.
So we multiply
both sides by phi.
This becomes the
identity matrix.
And we have x equals phi times
this set of standard basis
vectors.
Any questions about that?
That probably went
by pretty fast.
But does everyone believe this?
We went through that.
We went through both examples
of how this equation is
true for the case where
lambda is a diagonal matrix
and the e's are the
standard basis vectors.
And if we solve for the
eigenvectors of this equation
where A has this form of
phi lambda phi transpose,
you can see that
the eigenvectors
are given by this matrix
times a standard basis vector.
So any standard basis
vector times phi
will give you an eigenvector
of this equation here.
Let's push on.
And the eigenvalues are
just these diagonal elements
of this lambda.
What are these?
So now, we're going to figure
out what these things are,
and how to just
see what they are.
These eigenvectors
here are given by phi
times a standard basis vector.
So phi is a rotation
matrix, right?
So phi times a standard
basis vector is just what?
It's just a standard
basis vector rotated.
So let's just solve
for these two x's.
We're going to take phi, which
was this 45-degree rotation
matrix, and we're
going to multiply it
by the standard basis
vector in the x direction.
So what is that?
Just multiply this out.
You'll see that this is just a
vector along a 45-degree line.
So this eigenvector, this
first eigenvector here,
is just a vector on the
45-degree line, 1 over root 2.
It's a unit vector.
That's why it's got the
1 over root 2 in it.
The second eigenvector
is just phi times e2.
So it's a rotated version of the
y standard basis vector, which
is 1 over root 2 minus 1, 1.
That's this vector.
So our two eigenvectors we
derived for this matrix that
produces this stretch along
a 45-degree line, the two
eigenvectors are the
vector, 45-degree vector
in this quadrant, and
the 45-degree vector
in that quadrant.
Notice it's just a
rotated basis set.
So notice that the
eigenvectors are just
the columns of our
rotated matrix.
So let me recap.
If you have a matrix that
you've constructed like this,
as a matrix that produces a
stretch in a rotated frame,
the eigenvalues are just the
diagonal elements of the lambda
matrix that you put in
there to build that thing,
to build that matrix.
And the eigenvectors
are just the columns
of the rotation matrix.
OK, so let me summarize.
A symmetric matrix can
always be written like this,
where phi is a rotation matrix.
And lambda is a
diagonal matrix that
tells you how much the
different axes are stretched.
The eigenvectors of this matrix
A are the columns of phi.
They are the basis vectors,
the new basis vectors,
in this rotated basis set.
So remember, we can
[AUDIO OUT] this rotation
matrix as a set of basis
vectors, as the columns.
And that set of basis
vectors are the eigenvectors
of any matrix that you
construct like this.
And the eigenvalues are just the
diagonal elements of the lambda
that you put in there.
All right, any
questions about that?
For the most part,
we're going to be
working with matrices
that are symmetric,
that can be built like this.
So eigenvectors are not unique.
So if x eigenvector of A,
then any scaled version of x
is also an eigenvector.
Remember, an
eigenvector is a vector
that when you multiply
it by a matrix
just gets stretched
and not rotated.
What that means is that any
vector in that direction
will also be stretched
and not rotated.
So eigenvectors are not unique.
Any scaled version
of an eigenvector
is also an eigenvector.
When we write down
eigenvectors of a matrix,
we usually write
down unit vectors
to avoid this ambiguity.
So we usually write
eigenvectors as unit vectors.
For matrices of n
dimensions, there
are typically n different
unit eigenvectors--
n different vectors in
different directions that
have the special properties
that they're just stretched
and not rotated.
So for our two-dimensional
matrices that produce stretch
in one direction, the
special directions are--
sorry, so here is a
two-dimensional, two-by-two
matrix that produces a
stretch in this direction.
There are two eigenvectors,
two unit eigenvectors,
one in this direction and
one in that direction.
And notice, that because
the eigenvectors are
the columns of this
rotation matrix,
the eigenvectors form a
complete orthonormal basis set.
And that is true.
That statement is true
only for symmetric matrices
that are constructed like this.
So now, let's calculate
what the eigenvalues are
for a general two-dimensional
matrix A. So here's our matrix
A. That's an eigenvector.
Any vector x that
satisfies that equation
is called an eigenvector.
And that's the
eigenvalue associated
with that eigenvector.
We can rewrite this
equation as A times
x equals lambda i times x--
just like A equals b,
then equals 1 times b.
We can subtract that
from both sides,
and we get A minus lambda
i times x equals zero.
So that is a different way of
writing an eigenvalue equation.
Now, what we're to
do is we're going
to solve for lambdas that
satisfy this equation.
And we only want solutions
where x is not equal to zero.
So this is just a matrix.
A minus lambda i
is just a matrix.
So how do we know whether
this matrix has solutions
where x is not equal to zero?
Any ideas?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Is, so what do
we need the determinant to do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Has to be zero.
If the determinant of this
matrix is not equal to zero,
then the only solution to this
equation is x equals zero.
OK, so we solve this equation.
We ask what values of
lambda give us a zero
determinant in this matrix.
So let's write down
an arbitrary A,
an arbitrary two-dimensional
matrix A, 2D, 2 by 2.
We can write A minus
lambda i like this.
Remember, lambda i is just
lambdas on the diagonals.
The determinant of
A minus lambda i
is just the product of
the diagonal elements
minus the product of the
off-diagonal elements.
And we set that equal to zero.
And we solve for lambda.
And that just looks
like a polynomial.
OK, so the solutions
to that polynomial
solve what's called the
characteristic equation
of this matrix A. And
those are the eigenvalues
of this arbitrary matrix A,
this 2D, two-by-two matrix.
So there is
characteristic equation.
There is the
characteristic polynomial.
We can solve for lambda just
by using the quadratic formula.
And those are the eigenvalues
of A. Notice, first of all,
there are two of them
given by the two roots
of this quadratic equation.
And notice that they
can be real or complex.
They can be complex.
They are complex in general.
And they can be
real, or imaginary,
or have real and
imaginary components.
And that just depends on
this quantity right here.
If what's inside this
square root is negative,
then eigenvalues
will be complex.
If what's inside the
square root is positive,
then the eigenvector
will be real.
So let's find the eigenvalues
for a symmetric matrix.
a, d on the diagonals and
b on the off-diagonals.
So let's see what happens.
Let's plug these
into this equation.
The 4bc becomes 4b squared.
And you can see
that this thing has
to be greater than zero
because a minus d squared has
[INAUDIBLE] has to be positive.
And b squared has
to be positive.
And so that quantity has
to be greater than zero.
And so what we find is
that the eigenvalues
of a symmetric matrix
are always real.
So let's just take
this particular--
just an example-- and let's
plug those into this equation.
And what we find is
that the eigenvalues are
1 plus or minus root 2 over 2.
So two real eigenvalues.
So let's consider a special
case of a symmetric matrix.
Let's consider a matrix where
the diagonal elements are
equal, and the off-diagonal
elements are equal.
So we can update this
equation for the case
where the diagonal
elements are equal.
So a equals d.
And what you find is
that the eigenvalues are
just a plus b and a minus b--
so a plus b and a minus b.
And the eigenvectors
can be found just
by plugging these eigenvalues
into the eigenvalue equation
and solving for
the eigenvectors.
So I'll just go through
that real quick--
a times x.
So we found two
eigenvalues, so there are
going to be two eigenvectors.
We can just plug that
first eigenvalue into here,
call it lambda plus.
And now, we can solve for
the eigenvector associated
with that eigenvalue.
Just plug that in, solve for x.
What you find is that the x
associated with that eigenvalue
is 1, 1-- if you just
go through the algebra.
So that's the
eigenvector associated
with that eigenvalue.
And that is the
eigenvector associated
with that eigenvalue.
So I'll just give you a hint.
In most of the
problems that I'll
give you to deal with
on an exam or many
of the ones in the
problem sets, I
think, in the
problem set will have
a form like this and
[INAUDIBLE] eigenvectors
along a 45-degree axis.
So if you see a
matrix like that,
you don't have to
plug it into MATLAB
to extract the eigenvalues.
You just know that
the eigenvectors
are on the 45-degree axis.
So the process of writing
a matrix as phi lambda phi
transpose is called
eigen-decomposition
of this matrix A. So
if you have a matrix
that you can write
down like this,
in that form, it's
called eigen-decomposition.
And the lambdas, the diagonal
elements of this lambda matrix,
are real.
And they're the eigenvalues.
The columns of phi
are the eigenvalues,
and they form an
orthogonal basis set.
And this, if you
take this equation
and you multiply it
on both sides by phi,
you can write down that equation
in a slightly different form--
A times phi equals phi lambda.
This is a matrix way,
a matrix equivalent,
to the set of equations
that we wrote down earlier.
So remember, we wrote down
this eigenvalue equation that
describes that when you
multiply this matrix A times
an eigenvector equals lambda
times the eigenvector,
this is equivalent to writing
down this matrix equation.
So you'll often
see this equation
to describe the form of
the eigenvalue equation
rather than this form.
Why?
Because it's more compact.
Any questions about that?
We've just piled up all of
these different f vectors
into the columns of this
rotation matrix phi.
So if you see an
equation like that,
you'll know that
you're just looking
at an eigenvalue
equation just like this.
Now in general, when you want
to do eigen-decomposition,
when you have a symmetric
matrix that you want
to write down in this form.
It's really simple.
You don't have to go
through all of this stuff
with the characteristic
equation,
and solve for the eigenvalues,
and then plug them in here,
and solve for the eigenvectors.
You can do that if
you really want to.
But most people don't because in
two dimensions, you can do it.
But in higher dimensions,
it's very hard or impossible.
So what you typically do is just
use the eig function in MATLAB.
If you just use this
function eig on a matrix,
it will return the
eigenvectors and eigenvalues.
So here, I'm just
constructing a matrix A--
1.5, 0.5, 0.5, and
1.5, like that.
And if you just use
the eig function,
it returns the eigenvectors
as the columns of the matrix
and the eigenvalues as the
diagonals of this matrix.
So you have to pass it.
Arguments F and V
equals eig of A.
And it returns eigenvectors
and eigenvalues.
Any questions about that?
So let's push on toward doing
principal components analysis.
So this is just the
machinery that you use.
Oh, and I think I had one more
panel here just to show you
that if you take F and
V, you can reconstruct A.
So A is just F, V, F transpose.
F is just phi in the
previous equation.
And V is the lambda.
Sorry, they didn't
have phi and lambda,
and they're not options.
For variable names,
I used F and V.
And you can see that F, V, F
transpose is just equal to A.
Any questions about that?
No?
All right, so let's
turn to how do
you use eigenvectors and
eigenvalues to describe data.
So I'm going to briefly
review the notion of variance,
what that means in
higher dimensions,
and how you use a covariance
matrix to describe data
in high dimensions.
So let's say that we have
a bunch of observations
of a variable x--
so this is now just a scaler.
So, we have m
different observations,
x superscript j is the j-th
observation of that data.
And you can see that if you make
a bunch of measurements of most
things in the world,
you'll find a distribution
of those measurements.
Often, they will be
distributed in a bump.
You can write down the
mean of that distribution
just as the average value
overall distributions
by summing together
all those distributions
and dividing by the
number of observations.
You can also write down the
variance of that distribution
by subtracting the mean from
all of those observations,
squaring that difference
from the mean,
summing up over
all observations,
and dividing by m.
So let's say that we now have
m different observations of two
variables, pressure
and temperature.
We have a distribution
of those quantities.
We can describe that observation
of x1 and x2 as a vector.
And we have m different
observations of that vector.
You can write down the mean
and variance of x1 and x2.
So for x1, we can write
down the mean as mu1.
We can write down
the variance of x1.
We can write down the
mean and variance of x2,
of the x2 observation.
And sometimes,
that will give you
a pretty good description
of this two-dimensional
observation.
But sometimes, it won't.
So in many cases, those
variables, x1 and x2,
are not correlated
with each other.
They're independent variables.
In many cases, though, x1 and
x2 are dependent on each other.
The observations of x1 and x2
are correlated with each other,
so that if x1 is big,
x2 also tends to be big.
In these two cases, x1 can
have the same variance.
x2 can have the same variance.
But there's clearly
something different here.
So we need something
more than just describing
the variance of x1 and x2
to describe these data.
And that thing is
the covariance.
It just says how do
x1 and x2 covary?
If x1 is big, does x2
also tend to be big?
In this case, the
covariance is zero.
covariance is positive.
So we're taking if a
fluctuation of x1 above the mean
is associated with a fluctuation
of x2 above the mean,
then these points will produce
a positive contribution
to the covariance.
And these points here will also
produce a positive contribution
to the covariance.
And the covariance here will be
some number greater than zero.
That's closely related
to the correlation, just
the Pearson correlation
coefficient, which
is the covariance divided
by the geometric mean
of the individual variances.
I'm assuming most of you have
seen this many times, but just
to get us up to speed.
So if you have data, a
bunch of observations,
you can very easily fit
those data to a Gaussian.
And you do that simply by
measuring the mean and variance
of your data.
And that turns out to be
the best fit to a Gaussian.
So if you have a bunch of
observations in one dimension,
you measure the mean and
variance of that set of data.
That turns out to be a best
fit in the least squared sense
to a Gaussian probability
distribution defined
by a mean and a variance.
So this is easy
in one dimension.
What we're interested in
doing is understanding
data in higher dimensions.
So how do we describe
data in higher dimensions?
How do we describe a Gaussian
in higher dimensions?
So that's what we're
going to turn to now.
And the reason we're
going to do this
is not because every
time we have data,
we're really trying to
fit a Gaussian into it.
It's just that it's a powerful
way of thinking about data,
of describing data
in terms of variances
in different directions.
And so we often think
about what we're
doing when we are looking
at high-dimensional data
is understanding
its distribution
in different dimensions as
kind of a Gaussian cloud
that optimally best fits the
data that we're looking at.
And mostly because
it just gives us
an intuitive about how to
best represent or think
about data in high dimensions.
So we're going to get
insights into how to think
about high-dimensional data.
We're going to develop that
description using the vector
and matrix notation that
we've been developing
all along because
vectors and matrices
provide a natural
way of manipulating
data sets, of doing
transformations of basis,
rotations, so on.
It's very compact.
And those manipulations
are really
trivial in MATLAB or Python.
So let's build up a Gaussian
distribution in two dimensions.
So we have, again, our Gaussian
random variables, x1 and x2.
We have a Gaussian distribution,
where the probability
distribution is proportional
to e to the minus 1/2
of x1 squared.
We have probability
distribution for x2--
again, probability of x2.
We can write down
the probability
of x1 and x2, the joint
probability distribution,
assuming these are independent.
We can write that as
the product of p--
the product of the two
probability distributions p
of x1 and p of x2.
And we have some Gaussian cloud,
some Gaussian distribution
in two dimensions that we
can write down like this.
That's simply the product.
So the product of
these two distributions
is e to the minus
1/2 x1 squared times
e to the minus 1/2 x2 squared.
And then, there's
a constant in front
that just normalizes, so that
the total area under that curve
is just 1.
We can write this as
e to the minus 1/2 x1
squared plus x2 squared.
And that's e to the minus
1/2 times some distance
from the origin.
So it falls off exponentially
in a way that depends only
on the distance from the
origin or from the mean
of the distribution.
In this case, we set
the mean to be zero.
Now, we can write that distance
squared using vector notation.
It's just the square
magnitude of that vector x.
So if we have a vector x
sitting out here somewhere,
we can measure the distance
from the center of the Gaussian
as the square magnitude of
x, which is just x dot x,
or x transpose x.
So we're going to
use this notation
to find the distance of a vector
from the center of the Gaussian
distribution.
So you're going to see a
lot of x [INAUDIBLE] axis.
So this distribution
that we just built
is called an isotropic
multivariate Gaussian
distribution.
And that distance d is called
the Mahalanobis distance,
which I'm going to say
as little as possible.
So that distribution now
describes how these points--
the probability of finding
these different points
drawn from that distribution
as a function of their position
in this space.
So you're going to
draw a lot of points
here in the middle
and fewer points
as you go away at
larger distances.
So this particular
distribution that I made here
has one more word in it.
It's an isotopic multivariate
Gaussian distribution
of unit variance.
And what we're
going to do now is
we're going to build up all
possible Gaussian distributions
from this distribution by simply
doing matrix transformations.
So we're going to start by
taking that unit variance
Gaussian distribution and
build an isotopic Gaussian
distribution that has
an arbitrary variance--
that means an arbitrary width.
We're then going to build a
Gaussian distribution that
can be stretched arbitrarily
along these two axes, y1
and y2.
And we're going to do that
by using a transformation
with a diagonal matrix.
And then, what we're going to do
is build an arbitrary Gaussian
distribution that can
be stretched and worked
in any direction by using a
transformation matrix called
a covariance matrix,
which just tells you
how that distribution
is stretched
in different directions.
So we can stretch it in
any direction we want.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why is [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: OK,
the distance squared
is the square of magnitude.
And the square of magnitude
is x dot x, the dot product.
But remember, we can write
down the dot product in matrix
notation as x transpose x.
So if we have row vector
times a column vector,
you get the dot product.
Yes, Lina.
AUDIENCE: What does
isotropic mean?
MICHALE FEE: OK, isotropic
just means the same
in all directions.
Sorry, I should
have defined that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
when you stretched it,
it's not isotropic?
MICHALE FEE: Yes, these are
non-isotropic distributions
because they're different.
They have different variances
in different directions.
So you can see that this
has a large variance
in the y1 direction and a small
variance in the y2 direction.
So it's non-isotropic.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Why do
you [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHALE FEE: Right here.
OK, think about this.
Variance, you put into
this Gaussian distribution
as the distance squared
over the variance squared.
It's distance squared
over a variance, which
is sigma squared.
Here it's distance
squared over a variance.
Does that makes sense?
It's just that in
order to describe
these complex stretching and
rotation of this Gaussian
distribution in
high-dimensional space,
we need a matrix to do that.
And that covariance matrix
describes the variances
in the different direction
and essentially the rotation.
Remember, this distribution
here is just a distribution
that's stretched and rotated.
Well, we learned how to build
exactly such a transformation
by taking the product of
phi transpose lambda phi.
So we're going to use this to
build these arbitrary Gaussian
distributions.
OK, so I'll just go
through this quickly.
If we have an isotopic unit
variance Gaussian distribution
as a function of
this vector x, we
can build a Gaussian
distribution
of arbitrary variance by
writing down a y that's
simply sigma times x.
We're going to
transform x into y,
so that we can write
down a distribution that
has an arbitrary variance.
Here this is variance 1.
Here this is sigma squared.
So let's make just a change
of variables y equals sigma x.
So now, what's the
probability distribution
as a function of y?
Well, there's
probability distribution
as a function of x.
We're simply going to
substitute y equals sigma x
with x equals sigma inverse y.
We're going to substitute
this into here.
The Mahalanobis
distance is just x
transpose x, which is just
sigma inverse y transpose sigma
inverse y.
And when you do that, you
find that the distance squared
is just y transpose
sigma to the minus 2y.
So there is our
Gaussian distribution
for this distribution.
There's the expression for
this Gaussian distribution
with a variance sigma.
We can rewrite this
in different ways.
Now, let's build a
Gaussian distribution
that stretched arbitrarily in
different directions, x and y.
We're going to do
the same trick.
We're simply going to make
a transformation y equals
matrix, diagonal matrix, s
times x and substitute this
into our expression
for a Gaussian.
So x equals s inverse y.
The Mahalanobis distance
is given by x transpose x,
which we can just get down here.
Let's do that with
this substitution.
And we get an s squared
here, s inverse squared,
which we're just going to
write as lambda inverse.
And you can see that
you have these variances
along the diagonal.
So if that's lambda
inverse, then lambda
is just a matrix of
variances along the diagonal.
So sigma 1 squared is the
variance in this direction.
Sigma 2 squared is the
I'm just showing you how
you make a transformation
to this vector x
into another vector y
to build up a representation
of this effective distance
from the center of distribution
for different kinds
of Gaussian distributions.
And now finally, let's
build up an expression
for a Gaussian distribution
with arbitrary variance
and covariance.
So we're going to
make a transformation
of x into a new vector y using
this rotated stretch matrix.
We're going to substitute this
in, calculate the Mahalanobis
distance--
is now x transpose x.
Substitute this and solve
for the Mahalanobis distance.
And what you find is
that distance squared
is just y transpose phi lambda
inverse phi transpose times y.
And we just write that as y
transpose sigma inverse y.
So that is now an expression
for an arbitrary Gaussian
distribution in
high-dimensional space.
And that distribution is
defined by this matrix
of variances and covariances.
Again, I'm just writing down
the definition of sigma inverse
here.
We can take the inverse
of that, and we see that
our covariance-- this is
called a covariance matrix--
it describes the
variance and correlations
of those different
dimensions as a matrix.
That's just this
rotated stretch matrix
that we been working with.
And that's just the same
as this covariance matrix
that we described
for distribution.
I feel like all that didn't
come out quite as clearly
as I'd hoped.
But let me just
summarize for you.
So we started with an isotopic
Gaussian of unit variance.
And we multiplied that vector,
we transformed that vector x,
by multiplying it by sigma
so that we could write down
a Gaussian distribution
of arbitrary variance.
We transformed that vector
x with a diagonal covariance
matrix to get arbitrary
stretches along the axes.
And then, we made another
kind of transformation
with an arbitrary stretch
and rotation matrix
so that we can now write down
a Gaussian distribution that
has arbitrary stretch and
rotation of its variances
in different directions.
So this is the punch
line right here--
that you can write down
the Gaussian distribution
with arbitrary
variances in this form.
And that sigma right there
is just the covariance matrix
that describes how wide
that distribution is
in the different directions
and how correlated
those different directions are.
I think this just summarizes
what I've already said.
So now, let's compute the
covariance matrix from data.
So now, I've shown
you how to represent
Gaussians in high
dimensions that
have these arbitrary variances.
Now, let's say that I
actually have some data.
How do I fit one of
these Gaussians to it?
And it turns out that
it's really simple.
It's just a matter
of calculating
this covariance matrix.
So let's do that.
So here is some
high-dimensional data.
Remember that to fit a
Gaussian to a bunch of data,
all we need to do
is to find the mean
and variants in one dimension.
For higher dimensions,
we just need
to find the mean and
the covariance matrix.
So that's simple.
So here's our set
of observations.
Now, instead of being
scalars, they're vectors.
First thing we do is
subtract the mean.
So we calculate
the mean by summing
all of those observations,
dividing those numbers,
divide by m.
So there we find the mean.
We compute a new data set
with the mean subtracted.
So from every one of
these observations,
we subtract the mean.
And we're going to call that z.
So there is our mean
subtracted here.
I've subtracted the mean.
So those are the x's.
Subtract the mean.
Those are now our z's,
our mean-subtracted data.
Does that makes sense?
Now, we're going to calculate
this covariance matrix.
Well, all we do is
we find the variance
in each direction
and the covariances.
So it's going to be a matrix
in low-dimensional data.
It's a two-by-two matrix.
So we're going to find the
variance in the z1 direction.
It's just z1 times z1, summed
over all the observations,
divided by m.
Th variance in the z2
direction is just the sum
of z2, j, z2, j divided by m.
The covariance is
just the cross terms,
z1 one times z2 and z2 times z1.
Of course, those are
equal to each other.
So in a covariance
matrix, it's symmetric.
So how do we calculate this?
It turns out that in MATLAB,
this is super-duper easy.
So if this is our vector,
that's our vector, one
of our observations, we can
compute the inner product
z transpose z.
So the inner product
is just z transpose z,
which is z1, z2, z1, z2.
That's the square
magnitude of z.
There's another kind of product
called the outer product.
Remember that.
So the outer product
looks like this.
This is a 1 by 2.
That's a rho vector
times a column
vector is equal to a scalar.
1 by 2 times 2 by 1 equals by
1 by 1-- two rows, one column--
times 1 by 2, gives you a 2 by
2 matrix that looks like this.
z1 times z1, z1,
z2, z1, z2, z2, z2.
Why?
It's z1 times z1 equals that.
z1 times z2, z2 z1, one z2 z2.
So that outer product
already gives us
the components to compute
the correlation matrix.
So what we do is we
just take this vector,
z the j-th observation
of this vector z,
and multiply it by the j-th
observation of this vector z
transpose.
And that gives us this matrix.
And we sum over all this.
And you see that is exactly
the covariance matrix.
So if we have m
observations of vector z,
we put them in matrix form.
So we have a big,
long data matrix.
Like this.
There are m observations of
this two-dimensional vector z.
The data dimension, the data
vector has, mentioned 2.
Their are m observations.
So m is the number of samples.
So this is an n-by-m matrix.
So if you want to compute
the covariance matrix,
you just in MATLAB,
literally do z.
This big matrix z times
that matrix transpose.
And that automatically finds
the covariance matrix for you
in one line of MATLAB.
There's a little trick to
subtract the mean easily.
So remember, your original
observations are x.
You compute the mean
across the rows.
Thus, you're going you're going
to sum across columns to give
you a mean for each row.
That gives you a mean of that
first component of your vector,
mean of the second component.
That's really easy in the lab.
mu is the mean of x summing
cross the second component.
That gives you a
mean vector and then
you use repmat to fill that
mean out in all of the columns
and [INAUDIBLE] subtract
this mean from x
to get this data matrix z.
So now, let's apply those
tools to actually do
some principal
components analysis.
So principal components
analysis is really amazing.
If you look at single nucleotide
polymorphisms and populations
of people, there are
like hundreds of genes
that you can look at.
You can look at different
variations of a gene
across hundreds of genes.
But it's this enormous data set.
And you can find
out which directions
in that space of genes
give you information
about the genome of people.
And for example, if you
look at a number of genes
across people with
different backgrounds,
you can see that they're
actually clusters corresponding
to people with
different backgrounds.
You can do
single-cell profiling.
So you can do the same thing in
different cells with a tissue.
So you look at RNA
transcriptional profiling.
You see what are the
genes that are being
expressed in individual cells.
You can do principal
components analysis
of those different
genes and find
clusters for different
cell types within a tissue.
This is now being applied very
commonly in brain tissue now
to extract different cell types.
You can use images and find out
which components of an image
actually give you information
about different faces.
So you can find a bunch
of different faces,
find the covariance
matrix of those images,
take that, do eigendecomposition
on that covariance matrix.
And extract what are
called eigenfaces.
These are dimensions on which
the images carry information
about face identity.
You can use principal
components analysis
to decompose spike waveforms
into different spikes.
This is a very common way
of doing spike sorting.
So when you stick an
electrode in the brain,
you'd record from
different cells
at the end of the electrode.
Each one of those has
a different way of form
and you can use this method to
extract the different waveforms
people have even
recently used this
now to understand the
low-dimensional trajectories
of movements.
So if you take a movie--
SPEAKER: After tracking,
a reconstruction
of the global trajectory can
be made from the stepper motor
movements, while the local
shape changes of the worm
can be seen in detail.
MICHALE FEE: OK, so here
you see a c elegans,
a worm moving along.
This is an image, so it's
a very high-dimensional.
There are 1,000
pixels in this image.
And you can decompose that
image into a trajectory
in a low-dimensional space.
And it's been used to
describe the movements
in a low-dimensional
space and relate
to a representation
of the neural activity
in low dimensions as well.
OK, so it's a very
powerful technique.
So let me just first demonstrate
PCA on just some simple 2D
data.
So here's a cloud
of points given
by a Gaussian distribution.
So those are a
bunch of vectors x.
We can transform those vectors
x using phi s phi transpose
to produce a Gaussian, a cloud
of points with a Gaussian
distribution, rotated
at 45 degrees,
and stretched by 1.7-ish along
one axis and compressed by that
amount along another axis.
So we can build this rotation
matrix, this stretch matrix,
and build a
transformation matrix--
r, s, r transpose.
Multiply that by x.
And that gives us
this data set here.
OK, so we're going
to take that data
set and do principal
components analysis on it.
And what that's
going to do is it's
going to find the dimensions
in this data set that
have the highest variance.
It's basically going
to extract the variance
in the different dimensions.
So we take that set of points.
We just compute the
covariance matrix
by taking z, z transpose,
times 1 over m.
That computes that
covariance matrix.
And then, we're going to use
the eig function in MATLAB
to extract the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues
of the covariance
matrix OK, so q--
we're going to call q
is the variable name
for the covariance matrix
it's zz transpose over m.
Call eig of q.
That returns the
rotation matrix.
And that rotation matrix,
the columns of which
are the eigenvectors, it returns
the matrix of eigenvalues,
the diagonal elements
are the eigenvalues.
Sometimes, you need to
do a flip-left-right
because I sometimes return
the lowest eigenvalues first.
But I generally want to plot put
the largest eigenvalue first.
So there's the largest one,
there's the smallest one.
And now, what we do,
is we simply rotate.
We [AUDIO OUT] basis.
We can rotate this data
set using the rotation
matrix that the principal
components analysis found.
OK, so we compute the
covariance matrix.
Find the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues
of the covariance
matrix right there.
And then, we just
rotate the data
set into that new basis of
eigenvectors and eigenvalues.
It's useful for clustering.
So if we have two clusters,
we can take the clusters,
compute the covariance matrix.
Find the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues
of that covariance matrix.
And then, rotate the
data set into a basis set
in which the dimensions
in the data on which
variances largest are along
the standard basis vectors.
Let's look at a problem
in the time domain.
So here we have a couple
of time-dependent signals.
So this is some amplitude
as a function of time.
These are signals
that I constructed.
They're some wiggly function
that I added noise to.
What we do is we take each
one of those times series,
and we stack them up
in a bunch of columns.
So our vector is now a
set of 100 time samples.
So there is a vector of
100 different time points.
Does that make sense?
And we have 200 observations of
those 100-dimensional vectors.
So we have a data vector
x that has columns.
That are hundreds dimensional.
And we have 200 of
those observations.
So it's 100-by-200 matrix.
100-by-200 matrix.
We do the means subtraction
we subtract the mean using
that trick that I showed you.
Compute the covariance matrix.
So there we compute the mean.
We subtract the
mean using repmat.
Subtract the mean from
the data to get z.
Compute the covariance
matrix Q. That's
what the covariance matrix
looks like for those data.
And now, we plug it into eig
to extract the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues.
OK, so extract F and V. If
we look at the eigenvalues,
you can see that
there are hundreds
eigenvalues because those
data have 100 dimensions.
So there are
hundreds eigenvalues.
You could see that two of
those eigenvalues are big,
and the rest are small.
This is on a log scale.
What that says is
that almost all
of the variance in these data
exist in just two dimensions.
It's 100-dimensional space.
But the data are living
in two dimensions.
And all the rest is noise.
Does that makes sense?
So what you'll typically
do is take some data,
compute the covariance
matrix, find the eigenvalues,
and look at the
spectrum of eigenvalues.
And you'll very
often see that there
is a lot of variance in a
small subset of eigenvalues.
Then, it tells you that
the data are really
living in a
lower-dimensional subspace
than the full
dimensionality of the data.
So that's where your signal is.
And all the rest
of that is noise.
You can plot the
cumulative of this.
And you can say
that the first two
components explain over 60% of
the total variance in the data.
So since there are
two large eigenvalues,
let's look at the eigenvectors
associated with those.
And we can find those.
Those are just the first
two columns of this matrix F
that the eig function
returned to us.
And that's what those two
eigenvectors look like.
That's what the original
data looked like.
The eigenvectors, the
columns of the F matrix,
are an orthogonal basis set.
A new basis set.
So those are the first
two eigenvectors.
And you can see that
the signal lives
in this low-dimensional space
of these two eigenvectors.
All of the other
eigenvectors are just noise.
So we can do is we can project
the data into this new basis
set.
So let's do that.
We simply do a change of basis.
The f is a rotation matrix.
We can project our data
z into this new basis set
and see what it looks like.
Turns out, that's
what it looks like.
There are two clusters in
those data corresponding
to the two different wave forms
that you could see in the data.
Right there, you can
see that there are kind
of two wave forms in the data.
If you projected data into
this low-dimensional space,
you can see that there
are two clusters there.
If you projected data into other
projections, you don't see it.
It's only in this
particular projection
that you have these two
very distinct clusters
corresponding to the
two different wave
forms in the data.
Now, almost all
of the variance is
in the space of the first
two principal components.
So what you can
actually do is, you
can project the data into these
first two principal components,
set all of the other
principal components to zero,
and then rotate back to
the original basis set.
That is that you're setting
as much of the noise
to zero as you can.
You're getting rid
of most of the noise.
And then, when you rotate back
to the original basis set,
you've gotten rid of
most of the noise.
And that's called principal
components filtering.
So here's before filtering
and here's after filtering.
OK, so youve found the
low-dimensional space,
in which all the data sits,
in which the signal sits,
everything outside of
that space is noise.
So you rotate the data
into a new basis set.
You can filter out all
the other dimensions
that just have noise.
You filter back.
And you just keep the signal.
And that's it.
So that's sort of a brief
intro to principal component
analysis.
But there are a lot of
things you can use it for.
It's a lot of fun.
And it's a great
intro to all the other
amazing dimensionality reduction
techniques that there are.
I apologize for going over.